plus vraiment d'atomes crochus entre
l'état et la commune de fessenheim point
d'achoppement majeur la fiscalité
jusqu'à l'an dernier la ville et la
communauté de commune percevait 6
million trois cent mille euros de la
part d'edf qui produisait de
l'électricité sur son territoire sur
cette somme 3 millions quatre cent mille
euros était réinvesti dans des
infrastructures et services au niveau
local les deux millions 900 mille euros
restants étaient reversés au fonds
national de garantie individuelle des
ressources
le remplaçant de la taxe professionnelle
une somme auparavant versée par edf que
l'état ne veut plus assumer
résultat ce sont aux collectivités de
continuer à verser cette contribution à
hauteur de 2 millions 900 mille euros
impossible pour les élus et les armes en
main donné on sera on sera complètement
asséché si le dispositif n'est pas revue
assez rapidement je veux dire aux
quelque part c'est comme si on va on va
rembourser en fait tout ce que l'homme
puisque la centrale nous a rapporté
pendant quarante c'est pas à nous
habitants de payer cette part là c'est à
dire on sera obligé de déjà d'augmenter
les impôts pour pour encaisser les pour
absorber les 3,4 millions d'euros de
recettes qu'on ne que nous n'avons plus
mais en plus il faudra quasiment doublé
pour ne serait ce que paient cette part
de solidarité qu'on demande à à quelques
quelques contribuables versé arrêtés
respectivement le 22 février et le 30
juin 2020 les deux réacteurs de la
centrale de fessenheim ont causé une
perte de plus de 2000 emplois malgré les
15 millions d'euros alloués aux
territoires par l'état pour sa
reconversion
les élus estiment que c'est insuffisant
mais les acteurs économiques restent
optimistes
l'arrêt de la production électrique ne
devrait pas avoir le visage d'un drame
industrielle en majeure partie grâce à
la crise du coc vie 19 avec le
confinement il ya eu 1
une évasion qui s'est restreinte donc
les clients sont restés sur la zone de
chalandise des gens ont découvert le
magasin ont re découvert le magasin et
donc ça nous a permis de compenser le
départ on pense d'eux des agents
fessenheim est un territoire quand même
de qualité où il ya tous les services
toutes les infrastructures s'est fait
très bon vivre à fessenheim les maisons
il ya du foncier il ya d'iliad et
d'immobilier donc voilà on pense qu'il
ya de nouvelles familles qui vont
arriver et ça commence déjà un haut
niveau d'infrastructures qui pourrait
sauver le territoire malgré l'arrêt de
la production électrique nucléaire
mais si la commune se voit contrainte de
continuer à verser les 2 millions 900
mille euros de solidarité sans
compensation le dynamisme dont elle
bénéficie aujourd'hui pourrait
rapidement se tarir